[Musique]
au milieu de cette nuit possessionnaise
des sportifs bravent le froid hivernal
avec le
sourire 17 porteur et donc TR jettes
avec une personne à mobilité réduite de
l'association run and ont participé au
10 km semicturnes de La Possession et
pour chacun d'eux le passage de la ligne
d'arrivée reste un moment d'émotion
comme pour Nelsy et sa
maman k non mais c'est toujours trop
parce que
l'ambion une
ambianceique touours
son la porter et en fonction du nombre
de porteur on va PIR le nomte c'est le
nombre de porteur qui va qui va
permettre de voir une VO deux VO TR Jes
je pense que aussi bien au niveau de des
porteurs bah je veux dire de déjà c'est
tous des grands sportifs donc c'est tous
des gens qui ont fait des Trail des des
qui courent régulièrement qui
s'entraînent et tout donc déjà c'est un
défi sportif et puis le fait de pouvoir
emmener ces personnes handicapées c'est
voilà c'est un plus quoi c'est ils
savent qu'ils font plaisir à toutes ces
personnes et et puis nous qui ont
organisateur c'est exactement la même
chose quoi organisé par l'association
sport loisir Océan Indien et Andy basket
de la possession cette course mélange
valide et non valide sur un même
parcours de 9 km urbains et pour la 2è
édition l'ambiance était assurée on pas
parti avec
valid même était là nous ça
rien ou c'était pour ouais c'était pour
s'amuser le déguisement
[Musique]
comme il est
beau pe pas louper ça quand même ah
ouais quand même tout de suite he et on
va plus vite comme ça oui oui oui parce
qu'en fait bah dans ce déguisement je
suis ben clar Ken donc logiquement j'ai
plus vite que tout le monde voilà
soutenu par le Conseil départemental
cette manifestation a duré une bonne
partie de la soirée sur la place du
festival
asket fauteuil électrique tout terrain
cet espace a offert simplement du
bonheur à tous d'une façon conviviale
pour preuve la remise des médailles ici
toutes les catégories ont été récompensé
un détail qui veut dire
[Applaudissements]
beaucoup c'est un plaisir de voir autant
de monde
participerant de monde en fauteuil
mobilité rédite participer à ce genre de
course c'est une bonne chose Enie dire à
T qui partip pas venez venez essayer du
moins comme disait pierre deer le
principal c'est de participer voilà tout
simplement et de prendre du plaisir
sportivement c'est un grand sportif qui
gagne ce 10 km François Lebon boucle
l'épreuve en 32 minutes 56 secondes un
bel exploit noyé dans une autre
performance celle d'apporter autant de
bonheur à autant de public en même
[Applaudissements]
temps
tout le monde est àc des sport c'est le
feu d'artifice voilà c'est le feu
d'artifice voilà c'est c'est la fin VI
le sport l'handicap tout les valid tout
merci Monsieur
[Musique]
ouais